parts of the Donald Trump blackmail file
have now been confirmed it's true in a
stunning turn of events after Donald
Trump wrote off the entire thing is
so-called fake news this is of course
the Trump Russia blackmail file released
in full by BuzzFeed it was confirmed
that outgoing President Obama and then
president-elect Trump had been briefed
about the existence of this file Trump
denied it called it all fake news we
later learned that a highly respected
former mi6 operative named Christopher
Steele compiled this blackmail file or
rather the information contained within
it and now brace yourselves US
investigators have independently
corroborated some parts of the dossier
I'm going to dig into it okay but let's
be super clear once again the opposite
of what Trump says is actually the truth
Trump said it's all fake the existence
of it is fake the briefings about it by
intelligence agencies didn't happen the
content is fake we then learned the
existence of the file is real we then
learned that indeed intelligence
agencies briefed both then
president-elect Trump and then outgoing
President Barack Obama what we didn't
yet know about the contents and now at
least some of the contents are being
confirmed now the confirmed stuff
doesn't relate to the most salacious
allegations right the Trump urination
fetish etc but it relates to
conversations that allegedly took place
and the intercepted data now confirms
that at least some of the conversations
alleged to have taken place by the
dossier did take place between exactly
the same individuals on the same days
and in the same locations as outlined in
the dossier according to officials and
sources of indicated pat that again the
confirmations don't verify that
everything in the dossier is true but it
continues to lend more and more
credibility to the contents until now US
intelligence and law enforcement said we
aren't able to or haven't been able to
verify any of the content of the
da that has now changed doesn't tell us
whether everything is true but it at
least tells us that not only does the
dossier exist not only were Trump and
Obama briefed about it but there are
parts of it which are indeed true
drastically different than what Donald
Trump wanted us to believe and to me I
mean the more salacious angles to this
don't really matter as much it doesn't
matter if Donald Trump has a urine
fetish I mean that doesn't really speak
to his qualifications or if there's any
wrongdoing there right but the collusion
stuff the blackmail stuff I mean that
could be an impeachable offense
absolutely and Donald Trump again
dismissed the entire thing at his only
news conference as president-elect in
January saying it's all fake news it's
phony stuff it didn't happen it's almost
like we should have paid attention from
the beginning since the dossier was
written by a highly credible and
well-respected person who has all of the
connections in Russia that he was
speculated to have think about this
during the Obama administration when any
random lunatic on the Internet had the
dirt on Obama Republicans went nuts
right whether it was Jerome Corsi about
Obama being gay or Michelle Obama being
a man or whatever the hell it was
or Alex Jones or whoever the internet
went crazy Republicans went crazy we now
have a highly respected mi6 officer who
spent months compiling this with his
direct Russian sources he says hey guys
I've got stuff oh well that's fake news
now we don't have to pay attention for
about that and you'll also notice that
in the first 48 to 72 hours after this
leaked online there were all these
common things guys this was a prank
started by an Internet message board
it's all fake you're not hearing that
anymore are you pat no you're not and
another great example of fake news is
that the President President Obama was
not born in the United States I mean
that was a fake news thing started by
Donald Trump himself and again coming
from these completely incredible
recesses of the Internet and the right
just rallying around it I wonder what
else we will find out it's true from the
Trump blackmail file we know at least
some of it is now true